[Music]
apparently i've grown up
but i still go to places i've always
dreamt of as a child
i grew up on a farm so there really no
other kids to play with so i ended up
just going into my imagination
my world is full of futuristic
superheroes laser beams spaceships and
constructions
[Music]
i thought i'd be an inventor
so i became an engineer
[Music]
but the imagination isn't really
encouraged when you're an engineer
[Music]
luckily i found my own path
[Music]
i try to maintain that sense of magic
and wonder that we often lose as adults
[Music]
i can actually be myself in this costume
i'm kind of expected to be unique and
unusual
suits me fine
[Music]
found this place to go to on a monday
night everyone goes crazy in the dark
i can actually shed some light on
something you don't normally see
it's a bit naughty on me
uh welcome to no light snow lycra
so when the lights go out no one's
watching you you know you can get away
with whatever you want
[Music]
feels like you are in some music video
it feels like everyone around you is an
amazing dancer super sexy
you know fantastically cool
when the lights come back on
some sort of transformation has happened
i don't know what they've been doing
there in the dark
you hear it in a part of it but i love
the way you can't see the transformation
the feeling i get when i'm dancing in
the dark when you're free and connected
with your body and with the community
has basically been the driving force
behind my heart
[Music]
[Music]
humidity
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city
people
culture
late night food
but there's something missing
it's there but you can't see it
the night sky
[Music]
this is the story about a small town in
colorado actually two small towns in
colorado that are devoted to space
westcliff has a population of 564
residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575.
this used to be a mining community and
then it evolved into a railroad
community and then into a ranching
community
we're always looking to do something
that will bring people into our
community and lately that seems to be we
need to invest in our sky
so they made life pollution their enemy
they darken their towns so that the
night sky could become their star
attraction have you ever seen the milky
way that goes from horizon to horizon
88 of the world's population has never
seen the milky way it's the most
magnificent thing in the world that's
what we see here
but for the towns to go dark they needed
to cover all of their lights
not just street lamps but the lights
outside every house and ranch near town
that wasn't easy this is a frontier town
and i can tell you
frontier people don't like being told
what to do
we had to win their hearts and minds it
took 10 years they passed ordinances
raised money to cover the street lights
and even build an observatory
and the darker the town became the more
people saw the light
this year the valley's dark sky was
designated as one of the darkest in the
world drawing visitors from all over
okay
might need a six-pack though
well i was really hoping we'd be able to
see saturn by now yeah me too
that a community would decide to dim its
lights and help everyone to appreciate
the beauty of the night sky is an
amazing thing
you come to a place like this
and
the stars just
burst
and it's remarkable
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
see the dark sky as our ancestors saw it
and i feel that we're a very special
place to be able to look at the stars as
people did thousands of years ago
it's a humbling thing
suddenly you realize you can almost
touch it
and you're now a part of the bigger
universe
and so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies that's what we're
trying to preserve
my name's tim ducette
i'm an amateur astronomer
and i'm also legally blind
kind of an oxymoron isn't it
[Music]
it turns out i can actually see the
night sky better than most people
probably better than you
[Music]
when i was younger
it's it's easy to become discouraged
you know realizing that you're never
going to drive a car that you'll never
be an astronaut
at least that's what you're told
i was born with congenital cataracts
they remove the lenses of my eyes and
widen my pupils
that left me with only about 10 of my
eyesight
for the average person their pupil
automatically adjusts for the amount of
light coming in it opens and closes but
for me my
pupil is open so it's always letting in
a lot of light
during the day
i see everything extremely bright
everything is overexposed
colors are are more vivid
but at night time the tables are turned
and it's like a curtain has been lifted
[Music]
when i was a teenager i went on some
additional surgery to improve my
eyesight
i got home from the hospital and i
looked up at the sky and at first i
thought i was actually having a detached
rat and i was seeing millions of spots
of light
and realized that
that was the milky way i was looking at
and it was
phenomenal
[Music]
at first i didn't really realize what
it had given me
it took 15 years later
to realize that
what i had was special
with my personal savings i built an
observatory on a hill near my house
and called it deep sky eye
when i'm looking through a telescope i'm
not wearing my glasses
and my eye is like a camera without a
lens
so it's focusing the light very clearly
onto my retina
i see a little bit extra light that most
people wouldn't see
you know you look at the orion nebula
and you know it looks like a fuzzy patch
but you know i kind of get a little bit
of purplish tinge to it
the sky here is like a tapestry of
interstellar dust
it looks like a velvet background you
know with diamonds all through it
it's absolutely amazing
my wife is also legally blind
she doesn't see very well at night but
most of the time when we're you know
walking or at the observatory i'll
explain to my wife what i'm seeing
she appreciates the night sky even
though she doesn't see it very well
[Music]
when i look through the telescope or
look up at the night sky
it makes you realize really that all
your problems with fact that you're
legally blind or or whatever it really
just doesn't matter
you realize that you're a part of this
universe
[Music]
you